avion de combat sous-marin drone missile
anti-chat et bien d'autres les
importations d'armes en Europe doublant
l'espace d'un an un réarmement amorcé
depuis 2014
ont déjà décidé d'augmenter leurs achats
d'armes
butter
nous voyons une nouvelle accélération de
ce processus
parmi les États qui ont le plus
développé leur arsenal les voisins
inquiets de la Russie la Pologne et la
Norvège
mais c'est évidemment l'Ukraine qui
concentre un tiers des importations
d'armes sur le Vieux Continent des
importations qui ont été multipliées par
plus de 60 l'an dernier résultat le pays
est devenu subitement la troisième
destination d'armement dans le monde
derrière le Qatar est l'Inde
l'Ukraine était intestinataire mineur
d'armes avant 2022 malgré la situation
dans laquelle elle se trouvait mais là
nous pouvons voir qu'elle a augmenté ses
importations d'armes et qu'elle en a
reçu beaucoup de toute une série d'États
européens et des Etats-Unis côté
exportateur la première place est
toujours assurée par les États-Unis
suivent ensuite la Russie et la France
mais la part de Moscou se réduit
drastiquement elle privilégie bien sûr
l'approvisionnement de sa propre armée